You've done amazing work.
Really, you should be proud
of all the hard work and
effort you put into learning Ember.
You've worked with Ember CLI,
Ember's file structure,
the handlebars templating language,
components and
templates, consuming services, and
handling user engagement with actions.
You now have a solid foundation to
continue learning more about Ember.
Yep, there's still more to it, but
the Ember docs are full
of helpful information.
I hope the app we created is your
first of many Ember apps to come.
As you're working on your next Ember
project, make sure to share with me, and
the other students in the forum.
I can't wait to see what you create.